good morning everybody it's uh Saturday
morning thanks for taking the time out
to come to this special presentation
about the order flows flow scalper now
I'm going to get started it's a little
bit early but I'll get started in about
a minute uh still waiting for some
people to come online but uh just sit
tight and we'll get started uh in about
30 seconds I'm just going through some
last minute checks making sure
everything is working fine so just uh
bear with me and we'll get started in a
second I'm not talking right now I'm
just uh going through some last minute
checks so I'll get started in a second
Jean okay guys so looks like everything
is working fine so let's get started all
right so good morning everybody should
be familiar with who I am um you know
this presentation is for people that are
interested in the orderflow scalper now
if you have a problem hearing me let me
know put something in the chat box
and I looking at the go-to webinar um
control panel it looks like everything
is fine acting normal so um let's get
started excuse me got the bit of a not a
sore throat but just a dry throat you
know I'm in I'm in the Chicago area and
it's quite cold so we got the heater on
even with the humidifier on it's still a
bit uh it's still a bit dry so what is
the flow scalp or what well let's first
today we'll talk about uh you know got
to go through the disclaimer you know
everybody knows that we're all adults
trading involves risk you know we're not
all Robin Hood Traders we I like to
think of us as you know even though
we're not considered professional
Traders we are smart enough to know that
you know trading involves risk so the
agenda for
today I want to talk a bit about the
flow scalper then I'm going to go
through the different indicators
settings right because there there's um
you know different ways you can adjust
how it looks on the chart
and um you know the strength and and Etc
but I'm want to talk about that then I
towards the end the third part of the
presentation I'm going to discuss
individual markets and the settings for
them so you know everybody trades
different markets on different time
frames and in general the settings are
going to remain the same whether you
know you're looking at a a one minute
chart a tick chart but there might be
you know depending on the market and its
volatility you're probably going to want
to to adjust um something to sort of not
you know curve fit it but you know
adjust it for the market and the time
frame that you're looking at okay
because you know you got to realize
whether you're trading um you know NQ is
going to trade even though you know it
moves the same as es you know it's a bit
more volatile so you know you you're
probably going to want to add um you
know one you know sort of adjust one or
two of the settings to sort of filter
out some of the noise just because of
the the overall volatility in the market
I to talk about that um you know in the
third part of today's presentation and
I'm going to show you you know I'm going
to go through
charts um you know I'm going to change
the settings on them you know the first
half will be you know just sort of
screenshots sort of talk about that but
the the last part will be you know on
ninja Trader showing you how when you
adjust the setting what it looks like
and how it affects it so flow scalper
runs on ninja Trader 8 you know all my
orderflows software runs on ninja Trader
8 you know sometimes ninja Trader gets
you know a a bad rep because you know
sometimes you know people got older
computers but you know what for me ninja
Trader has been fine even though I'm
sort of on got a LoveHate relationship
with the people at ninja Trader overall
the software is great you know and you
know I I have an account with several
Brokers one of which is ninja Trader
brokerage and I've never had a major
issue
and you know I did have an issue back on
you know I think it was 2015 or
something or you know where where the
system hung for literally you know a
couple minutes I had to log out log back
in while I was in a trade other than
that you know I've never really had a
problem so you know I find ninja Trader
pretty reliable you know it pays to have
a newer computer you know if you're
running
on um you know sometimes you know people
got old computers you know you can buy a
decent computer you don't need the fancy
um you know
$3,000 trading computer from you know
some of these trading computer uh
companies honestly you can get by with
an i5 you know with I prefer to have
more RAM 16 um gigs of RAM and you know
ideally have an SSD drive um and you can
get that stuff for you know $400 $500 at
least here in in the US and you know
monitors are cheap you could usually
hook up two or three monitors to that
now on ninja Trader 8 you need to enable
The Tick replay okay and I'll talk about
that later that's so you know if if
you're doing historical charting and you
want to see how you know how certain
settings work in a market you know
that's how you're going to want to have
it because you want to have the
indicator show up you know as soon as
you load a chart it will if it will show
up on the past data that's the big
difference between ninja Trader 7 and
ninja Trader 8 is the way it handles uh
data it's going to work on normal
Candlestick chart or orderflows Trader
chart it should work on the volum metric
chart which is the Ninja
Trader version of you know the footprint
chart so and it's going to work on
different time based charts like minute
chart you know 30 second chart um you
know five minute chart range based
charts uh tick based charts volume base
charts hakashi charts and kagi charts
now hakashi charts are sort of coming
into Vogue but uh kagi charts not many
people use it well ranco charts not so
much oh no they don't I don't use ranco
charts um you know some people some
other vendors have come out with these
ranco charts that are um you like uni
ranko and Etc I haven't tested them I
don't use those type of charts part of
the problem is you know trying to rec
recreate it on a historical database um
you can't um I just find honestly
personally I use uh mostly minute based
charts I do look at range based charts
and volume based charts I don't look at
tick based charts line break charts I'm
not sure I I I don't use those I'd have
to take a look maybe I'll I'll do that
later when I got ninja Trader up and
running now what makes the flow
scalper run basically well you know when
I was working on the flow scalper right
now people that know me and and Order
flows you know I've been involved in
trading with order flow for a long time
and you know there's a lot of tools out
there that
measure certain things in the order flow
right like I have other indicators out
there like the pulse right which looks
for a certain thing in the order flow or
the Delta scalper which looks for a
certain thing in the order flow but
where the flow scalper
differs is it picks
up the change in the order flow right
because you know generally you're going
to have order flow that's bullish and
Order flow that's bearish right rather
than just you know one thing happened
just like that in the order flow that
you know buyers all of a sudden jumped
into the market sometimes the move is
more subtle right because you got to
remember right big Traders they don't
necessarily want to just all jump in
pile into the market they they want to
finesse the mar finesse their order
without necessarily moving the market
and when you have you know several big
Traders
or companies doing that sort of at the
same time it it will show up in the
order flow so it doesn't just
concentrate on you know Delta or
imbalances or point of control or volume
it uses all
those all those different pieces of
information okay and it's
measuring where the change is is
occurring in the market right
so you got to remember right there's so
much trading going on and
sometimes these these little shifts are
hard to see you know especially if
you're looking at a footprint chart
if if you don't know what to look at you
know it it's kind of um I'll say useless
but you have to train yourself to know
what to look for right you got to be
picking up these different shifts you
know if if you've spent a lot of time
watching a dome or a lot of time
watching a footprint chart you've sort
of internalized all this information um
sort of the flow of trading that's going
on and that and you could sort of pick
up you could see the sort of the the
current you know the undertoe of the
market um starting to go in One
Direction and you know that's sort of
not not the highest level you could
reach as a Trader but you know that
that's the level where you know you sit
back and say yeah I I really got a firm
grasp on the direction of the market and
that's why I created the flow scalper to
help Traders see that current you know
see that change in the market okay
because you know really the hardest part
of trading with orderflow is putting the
pieces together right like I said you
know a lot of there's a lot of
indicators out there based on orderflow
but they're really looking at sort of
one little piece of information they're
not really taking into account
everything that's happening together
right you you you want to put everything
together and understand how how the
pieces are fitting
together
so excuse me um the signal
of the order of the flow scalper right
this is a footprint chart okay and if
this is the signal right up here at the
top this this red uh down arrow
okay what's what it's taking into
account is sort of what's happening
right in here right right as this Market
starts to turn and before it sells off
right it's telling me that the the order
flow has turned
bearish just as here it's telling me the
order flow has turned bullish right this
blue arrow now there's there's different
ways you could have it signaled on the
chart I'm going to talk about that as
well
um you know some people like to have
zones drawn out um some
people like to have you know some other
shape I prefer the triangle up triangle
down you know some people like to have
different colors you could adjust all
that okay so I'm going to get into those
set I'll get into that um when I get
into the individual
settings but I was going to take you
through some quick charts here
so I'll be talking about later when I
when I deal with um is are the different
markets because you know there there's a
way I code them like
551 okay so this is NASDAQ yesterday on
a one minute and there's basically a
couple settings that will apply to all
Market it's going to be 551 or it's
going to be uh 051 okay and you're going
to either adjust the first number or the
last number or the middle number
generally it's going to be the outside
then the inside but just show you how
you know with this the same settings you
know silver 551 now when flow scalper
was
first when I when I was working on it
okay initially all this time was you
know I wanted something that was going
to give me an indication of which way
the order flow was in the near term
because you know there's a certain
Market um that I trade
and I'm really just you know in and out
in and out in and out and I wanted to
know where the next few ticks were going
to come you know the next three or four
ticks were going to come and so I was
like I I I know that you I could look at
the order flow and and see it but I
wanted to have something
that um you know would would just
highlight highlight it to me on the
computer to make it easier to see part
of the reason is because it's it's a
market that trades at night uh it trades
in Asia
and honestly in the middle of the night
sometimes my my my faculties aren't
aren't there and I needed something that
would um put it up on the charts on
there so I'm GNA get to the questions a
little bit you know towards the end but
um or I'll try and take a break in
between just so I don't get sidetracked
but there's a lot of questions yes it
can be autot traded um it can
be
um what's the term set up in a software
markers I'm meeting with or talking with
Pablo to trying to get a special
training session with his markers and
show you how um how it works with
markers and you know how to set it up
and do do all that it's probably going
to be you know Christmas is this week so
I don't think this week it might be that
that time in between Christmas and New
Year's um I don't use Blood Hound but
you know my my indicators there there
are users that use Blood Hound with my
indicator um you know it's basically it
is a mark on the chart so it should be
able to um work with blood hound like I
said I know there's other users that use
my indicators that do use blood hound
and are able to get it uh going so but
I'll talk about that in you know a bit
later okay now this is British
pound okay and you can see settings are
slightly different the middle one is
still the same the middle one is the
strength the last one is contango the
second the first one is um the look back
period okay so it's basically
or 15 one or zero depending on the
market this last one is contango I'm
going to talk about that setting um a
bit later now this is Ultra Bond okay so
people gonna say oh my God Mike that's
so many signals right I that's that's
useless to me
well you know I know there's a lot of
questions right now coming in about
trading with markers or with blood hound
and for me I said when I when I first
created this uh tool right the way I
envisioned it was because I I I needed
something that was going to help me with
my
individual I hate to use the term
scalping but more short-term trading and
so I wanted to know as long as this
order flow was barish on the way down I
can stay in the trade just as if I'm
long in here what is the order flow
doing is it bullish or bearish now when
you're doing with you know when you're
setting up something on auto
trade sometimes you know you don't want
to see so many signals in there so
there's a way to filter that that out
which I I'll talk about later
but when I'm in a trade right I want to
know do I want to be cutting it you know
or or is this about as far as this
Market's going to move but if I'm in a
trade right and I see red you know down
it or down it I know the order flow is
still bearish okay so I can stay
um I could stay in
it is it the mees again this is the same
same settings right this is the the
micro e mini from
yesterday you that move at the end of
the session was just
uh was amazing um you know I think Dow
actually made a new High um ym made a
new high on on the close but again you
know you got to ask yourself what type
of Trader you are you a short-term
Trader are you a long-term Trader and
that's how one of these this first part
here you know where you says zero is you
know is going to change because that's
going to be a swing filter if you're
more of a momentum Trader or short-term
Trader um you're not going to want to
use the swing filter but I I'll go
through some examples um later on that
as I talk about the
settings this is the difference right if
you if you say mike that's too many
signals because um you know I I can't
that's too messy right well then you
probably want to enable a swing filter
to find reversals as opposed to
something that's more momentum based
right if if you're in a trade like me
personally if I'm in a trade I want to
know is the order flow still bullish or
still bearish okay whereas you know here
I'm just getting you know signals at
swing highs and and swing
lows so you know some questions that
came
in um you over the last couple days can
you use these on markers or blood hound
yes you could use them on markers I
don't use Blood Hound I have markers I
don't I don't use Blood Hound but users
that use my other indicators tell me
that it does work with Bloodhound is
this a new
tool um yes it's a new tool it doesn't
read order the the same things in the
order flow that some of the IND other
indicators do such as um pulse or
turns those look for very specific
things in the order
flow and you know I have orderflows
pulse indicator and orderflows Trader
3.0 how does this tool work with them
well again it's it's a different tool
you know it if if you're watching the
order flow okay on a footprint
chart okay I always say you know anytime
you get into a trade the the follow-up
trade has to be complementary to it so
you know any indicator that I have is
complimentary to the footprint chart
right footprint chart is for helping you
understanding what's happening going in
in the market
and you know it's you know as a Trader
you have to trade okay I I like I said I
I know everybody likes
to go Auto you know Auto Trade you know
basically build a trading robot and not
have to make much
decisions and you know because making
decisions often leads to making wrong
decisions but you know it's at I find
the best Traders are the ones that do
have um you want to call it you know
some discretion in their trading you
know by by being able to read the order
flow and say you know what this this you
know this move is weakening I don't
think there's much left to the move and
get out now you know conversely like I
said you know when you're when you're
auto trading you got your standard
takeprofit your your standard stoploss
well you know that that's all well and
good you know Everyone likes to sit here
and say you know I you I'm I'm getting
85% winning trades um you know this is
my my winning percentage um that's great
you know that that's that's good um but
you know the way the way I trade is I
use the auto trader I use markers to get
me in and I manage the trade from there
um based on reading the order flow so
the scalper does not replace you know
other tools um doesn't replace the pulse
doesn't replace order flows 3.0 all
right so let's take a look at under
the hood
okay so basically I'm going to go
through this real fast I just lifted
this from the user guide but you know I
just want people to understand because I
did get some questions um saying you
know hey I got a pop up on my uh Ninja
Trader saying you know this this
indicator is not licensed well you know
after you purchase it okay you're going
to get a license token so you're going
to have to add the flow scalper to ninja
Trader as you would any other add-on
okay and once it's added in then you're
going to go to the Chart click on
indicators find flow scalper okay you're
going to click on that then you're going
to click down here make sure you don't
have to click down here just look down
here when it says configured make sure
it shows up in
there and then you got to enter the
license token you just drop it in right
here copy and paste it from the email
and you're good to go okay you well then
you click apply then you click okay all
right so it's important that you put
your license token in if you don't put
your license token in if you think
you've just installed it and it's going
to work no when you try
to run it on a chart you're going to get
a popup saying it's not licensed so just
make sure you go through that quick step
of putting in your license token here
this is on the properties of the
indicator right so again when you open
up the indicator under the the available
indicators drop in your license token
there all right so in here right this
part that says settings this is the main
part that you're going to worry about um
adjusting right this is really the only
part part you got to spend some time um
some time with now the defaults again it
it's what it comes as a default doesn't
mean that's for every single Market out
there right because there's so many
different markets so many different time
frames that you know you're going to
want
to um adjust it accordingly for your
Market depending on the liquidity of
your
market so first one is the swing filter
okay now there's two parts of the Swing
filter there's the enable swing filter
and there's the swing period okay if you
do not enable it if it is there's no
check mark in here then it means you're
not using the swing filter and the swing
period doesn't matter doesn't matter
what you put in this box but if you
enable the swing filter it's going to
look at the swing period right so if you
have a swing period of five you know
that's sort of the average that that I
like um there's there's some basically
just my settings that I like is either
no swing filter enabled or swing filter
uh
a swing period of one
five I don't really go out Beyond um 10
but there are people I know that like to
look at something like uh 25 you know if
if it's a very volatile Market but I
find no swing filter which is basically
zero um one or
five
okay uh minimum bar volume requirement
now for most markets in the US this is
not really a factor um when you start
getting into thinner markets or even the
overnight session um you're going to
want to put a minimum bar volume for it
it to you know give you a signal right
you don't want to get a signal on a bar
that's got volume
of five contracts right because you know
what what do you think the order flow is
is going to be for a bar that's got five
contracts or some of these preceding
bars that that have basically two
contracts three it's not going to give
you much right so this is one way
to sort of filter out like I said you
know most markets in the US you know
definitely e- minis you know all the
major contracts in the US is is not
going to be an issue um you know you
start getting into some of these you
know mini russle or you know some of
these contracts that don't have a lot of
volume um at certain times of the day
you will probably want to use that now
there's there's um you know some
commodity
markets or you know some overseas
markets
are a little bit thinner so you know you
want to you would want to set um a
volume
requirement you know I I like 10 as as
sort of the minimum um you know maybe
you want to set it at 50 or 100 that's
up to you but I said most markets in the
US most of the time it's not something
you got to even think
about now the flow strength okay there
there's two flow strengths there's
contango and there's normal conditions
now
you'll see enable normal conditions
right it's got a check in it you'll
you'll most likely want to all this is
what you'll be using pretty much all the
time so just make sure there's a check
in
there and the flow strength is related
to you know if you have it enabled okay
so if you have it
disabled doesn't matter what you put in
there it needs to be
enabled now flow strength it it looks
for how strong the order flow
is happening right now so it's a scale
of 1 to
10 one is the bare
minimum five is average 10 is the
strongest right most markets you're
going to be you know anywhere between
two and five um you're going to want
to um you you don't want it too weak you
know if you set it to one you're going
to get a lot of signals um if you set it
to 10 you're going to get less
signals but when I five is the you know
is the average five is is the good
starting point for pretty much everybody
now again here's the settings minimum
one two is sort of starting point for
most markets even though I just said
five but you know you can go two two is
is a bit on the week you know three is
sort of mid- average four is average
five is
average the difference between four and
five is is kind of four five and six you
you can sort of lump them in but you
know the average would be five anyway um
seven you start to get pretty strong 10
is you know the strongest you go with 10
it's going to be you depending on the
market you're looking at you might not
get any signals um or you know might get
a couple signals in the middle of the
night it's it's very strong I said you
know if you're trading e- minis you set
it at
10 you're probably not going to get any
any um any signals it's it's too strong
for that particular Market but if you're
looking at other markets like
say uh top of my head I don't know bean
oil or soybean meal or wheat you know
you can probably you can use 10 you
won't get many signals but you'll get
some uh pretty strong signals generally
now contango this is a question that
that's come up a couple
times contango and contango flow
strength are related to each other and
when would you use it
now again to enable it you'd put a check
in there to enable any of these you have
to have a check in there okay so you can
see there's no check so right now it's
disabled to enable you'd put a check in
there Kango flow strength again the same
strength readings go for Kango that that
work for the normal conditions and the
reason that we have it split up
is contracts have different participants
in them okay and you know everyone is so
used to trading um you know the main
contracts you know the e- minis NASDAQ
and
um you know they're
they're they are cash
settled contracts that
are physically settled have a slightly
different characteristic because the
participants the the you don't have as
much retail participation in those
markets okay and what the flow scalper
does is it sort of takes that into
account and you know honestly when
you're looking at some commodity markets
right the the amount of retail trading
there is minuscule right it's maybe 5%
10%
and you you're going to want to have um
something that takes that into account
it
it's I'm trying to think of a of a I've
been trying to Rack my brain trying to
think of a a good way to to explain it
is you know it's basically you've got a
lot of retail money in the market that
or a lot of um fund Mark money in the
market
but that sort of drowns out Al
oftentimes a lot of the commercial um
participation right because like the
amount of retail money in or I'll say
retail money but retail Traders the
volume coming through in in retail um
from the trading public in markets such
as you know especially the micros um you
don't see that in other markets okay and
it it sort of having the contango in
there takes into account you know sort
of flushes out some of that that um
extra I hate to use the term noise but
you know sort of that that money you
because in other markets that that are
do I say dominated but have a lot of
commercial trading you you tend to
get better moves um you know like you
said you you look at these micro
contracts and you know people get
stopped out a lot because
there there's just so much back and
forth between you know the the smaller
Traders and you know sort of this it
it's the volatility is is increased a
bit by um smaller smaller groups of
Traders I don't know if that makes sense
to guys but that's that's why we put it
in there because you know I found that
in certain markets you know markets that
have a lot of commercial participation
it acts there's a there's a different
way it acts in the order flow because
when they come in you know they can come
in um quite
strong now tight markets okay this is
something that is important to me
and if you depending on the markets that
you're trading okay there's markets that
basically I call Flatline you know go
sideways activity where it just trades
basically the bid and the offer you know
say six bid at seven just trading there
for extended periods and you know maybe
you know 67 and then goes 78 trades 8
for small goes back to
67 um and and like that is you know
there there's it gets a little tricky
sometimes trying to read the order flow
okay and by having tight markets it's
what I call a tight Market basically you
know very you know bidas where it's not
moving right you know you look at um
NASDAQ for example okay you could have a
bid ask that's two points right eight
ticks wide especially on some days but
other markets you know it's going to be
one tick okay and you know if you're
analyzing the markets at night you know
in the overnight session from you know
the reopen at 5 o'clock Chicago time
basically until about um 6 AM Chicago
time um having the tight markets on
there is is going to help you with your
analysis if you disable it um it's going
to sort of ignore those those sideways
markets where even though there's
something happening in the order flow
and it's not really evident yet um by
having tight markets disabled it's just
going to throw the that that uh not that
time period but sort of the the that
activity out right it's not go going to
analyze it and the reason we we
separated that
from the the normal order flow is you
know specifically for those type of
markets right because it when Market's
moving
sideways on a
Market that's more liquid that that's a
different reason than a market going
sideways um on a very liquid market now
people sound alerts right you can use
the default ninja Trader sound alert so
to enable it you would click here right
it's disabled right here but you just
put a check mark in there anytime you
change one of these you got to click
apply all right and your ninja Trader
has I think four default alerts it's set
up for the um alert one you can actually
record your own you know say buy you
know sell you don't want to make the
sound alert very long um you
know you know when I was was working at
these um you know these Banks you know
one of the favorite alerts people like
to put on was was a cash register
ringing you know CH Ching um it's up to
you I personally the problem is if
you're looking at multiple markets
and Market starts moving and you have
sound alerts
enabled and they're all the same you're
going to get confused you might want to
sort of record your own it's just got to
be a wave file you just drop it in this
extension here ninja Trader 8 sounds
alert one you just change this part here
to whatever you want um whatever your
alert is like say you want to say hey e-
minis or you know NQ you don't want to
make a sound alert too long because you
know it it should just be short like I
don't know a second or two you don't
want to say uh um look at the e minis
because it's just too long if you got
other alerts going in they'll they'll
run into each other sound alert rearm in
seconds is 30 seconds so that's how long
it will will pass before before it
shoots off another alarm so that's
that's the main settings and and I'm
going to show you when you adjust them
on different
markets how they affect it so just
really quick the sound
alerts right you just go to your um PC
go to the drive uh the C drive go to uh
program files the x86 open up ninja
Trader go to sounds you just drop it in
here so these are the different sounds
you they' even got you know other alerts
um you know depending on the language
you have set up for Ninja Trader but for
English it's just it's in the main the
main folder but this is the URL right
here program files x86 ninjatrader 8
backback sounds alert one
wave so again you know if you're going
to change it with your own alert you
know just change this part here in the
setting it's the end here you'd have to
scroll to the end to to change it all
right so the trade entry signal
now a lot of my indicators now have this
what I call Trade entry signal okay so
you can either choose to use it or not
use it
and what it is
is the order flow moving in the
direction of the trade signal okay so
you'll see there there's two settings
there's trade price level in ticks and
there's trade validity in bars okay so
when you have it
enabled there's two settings you got to
worry about the first one is how far
from the close of the signal bar the
market has to move before a signal is
generated and the second choice that you
got to choose from is trade validity in
bars um that's how many bar bars the
market has to start moving in from the
bar with the signal so setting that I
use for all markets is 22 so what that
tells me is over the next two bars say I
get a the conditions are there saying
hey Mike you know the order flow is
bullish I don't necess just run in and
start buying right I want the order Flow
To You know the follow-up order flow to
confirm to me that um yeah it actually
is still bullish right so over the next
two
bars the the market has to move at least
two ticks before I get the signal now
some people say well you you're giving
up you know two ticks on on your entry
you know is is that's stupid well it
also keeps me out of Trades rather than
just going in you know just say oh gosh
you know the order flow is bullish I'm
just got to buy right now but if you
don't have that follow through order
flow and you don't want to be in that
trade you know because you know Mark
orderflow is constant right keeps moving
bullish bearish bullish bearish what you
want is bullish bullish bullish bullish
right and that's where the trade entry
signal is going to help because you know
even though it's bullish right here you
know depending on whatever reason um
that caused it to be bullish right now
there could be somebody you know at at
um you know JP Morgan or or credit Swiss
that's all a sudden you know portfolio
manager passes been order to sell 3,000
e minis okay so what was bullet
all of a sudden is bearish so you're not
going to get that that move that you
want because all of a sudden there's a
big bearish order flow coming into the
market but again you know you could
choose to use a trade entry signal um or
choose not to again it's up to you I I
prefer to use it just it keeps me out of
bad trades and there's times where you
know Market is trending trending
trending you don't want
to um you know fight a trend and you
know when a market is dropping you know
in One
Direction or just going parabolic right
there's going to be profit taking right
you you get those bounces in moves down
which is just you know people taking
profit and it looks bullish but it's
just profit taking and then what happens
the market Falls over it makes new lows
right this is where the trade entry
signal is is going to help you um stay
out of that uh stay out of those
bad um what you want to call it you know
the bad move so to speak you know where
the market is dropping dropping dropping
and then some buying comes in because
it's really just people covering their
short it looks bullish in the order you
think hey this is it you know our low is
being made and then once those people
cover their shorts there's no more
buying in the market and the market just
keeps dropping further now the the next
part is the visuals okay this deals with
um you know whether you want zones drawn
on your chart or not some people like to
have zones some people don't so just
really quick the signal box height in
ticks
is
um how uh what is that it's where to
start drawing The Zone in the bar
basically okay
and all this in here
2.5.5 again you don't really need to
adjust those unless you you really want
to um signal box opacity 25 basically is
how light or how dark you want the zone
to be drawn signal box with in bars zero
means it's turned off right it means
it's disabled um if you set it to five
it's going to draw it out um five bars
starting at the signal bar and the next
four bars if you want to do it three
it'd be the signal bar and the next two
bars some people on on some indicators
you set this like at at a higher number
25 or even 50 um because they want to
see what happens when the market comes
back to that level okay now signal Mark
displacement is how far above um or
below from the signal bar to draw the
the up or down triangle or whatever you
want to set it at now this part in here
the data series set up and this set of
visuals you don't need to touch those
okay just leave them as it is because
basically input series is what you're
looking at how it calculates on each
tick you know the label that appears up
in the the Cor corner of your chart and
maximum bars to analyze visual Auto
scale displacement zero display in data
box yeah same just so it appears on the
same chart you're looking at now the
last
part I didn't talk about the plots here
maybe I get to that later is where you
want them to app how you want it to
appear on the chart to Triangle up um
eight pixels you know if you want to
make it smaller you can you want to make
it bigger you can um yeah you go you can
go pretty big but on ly once you get
past 15 it's kind of big
contango me personally I keep them the
same color red and for sells blue for
buys if you're using contango and
normals if you want you can change the
contango to a different color you know
maybe um you know I don't know orange
and and green but I I don't discriminate
between either of them I treat them the
same so like I said you you can change
the color so for example right in this
case contango right these colors down
here under the plots I've changed to
Green for buys magenta which is kind of
a a purple for or pink for sells so you
can see this is a contango buy this is a
contango cell this is a regular cell
this is a regular normal buy normal buy
up here was a contango but you know I
would treat them the
same normal signals and contango signals
this is where they're the same color
here personally I keep them the same is
I I trade them the same um I said it's
it's I've added the contango feature for
a lot of these physical commodity
markets um yeah I know this is a lot of
information to digest it's don't worry
this is being recorded so um you know
you don't have to worry about it so you
could always refer back to this I'm
going to put this also in the download
page and you know I'll probably throw it
up on on YouTube as well so you have
access to it but um I know I'm going
through a lot especially if you know
this is the first time you're seeing
this and you haven't had a chance to uh
sort of go through the user guide or or
throw it up on a chart but
um it gets really uh really easy to use
so again the trade entry signal this can
be enabled or disabled right if if you
want to see every time a signal is
generated whether or not um you you
would just turn it on on okay but if you
want to see um you know when a signal is
generated and there's follow through
orderflow then you'll want to use trade
entry signal so with the trade entry
signal when enabled a signal is going to
print on your
chart immediately after the signal bar
not on the signal bar the if you're
using the zones The Zone will be drawn
on the signal bar but you won't get a um
triangle up or triangle down when
there's a
you won't get that on the signal bar so
what it means is when the conditions of
the flow scalper are met for a trade
signal to be generated the order flow in
the next bars need to be in the
direction of the trade signal again you
can decide how many ticks you want the
market to start moving in the direction
of the trade for a trade signal to be
generated I use two default is set to
two and slower moving markets you know
like um treasuries you could get away
with one if you're using a range-based
chart um you don't want to use one
because you know a lots of times you
know if you spend any time with a range
based chart you know anytime it just
breaks out the range by one tick it
often you know you see a lot of these
one tick reversals in a Range based
chart where it goes up one tick and then
it just reverts back into the previous
bar um so you might want to set it at
two again you can decide how many bars
you want the market to start moving in
the direction of the trade signal to be
generated I use two default is two so it
means the market has to move at least
these two ticks in the direction of the
trade within the next two bars to be
valid so that's it so if you have it
enabled a
blue Buy Signal triangle up will print
only after the signal bar is closed and
the next two bars over the next two bars
if it's going in that direction and the
same is for a cell right a red triangle
will only print after the signal bar
it's not going to print on the signal
bar it's going to print on the current
bar and once it prints it's not going to
change okay it's not going to reprint or
anything um if you just if you're not
using the trade entry signal and the
conditions are met in a bar okay as a
bar is
forming conditions can be met and then
they can based on the orderflow it can
disappear so once the bar is closed
whatever signal is drawn that's it but
as a bar is
forming it can go in it can go out right
the conditions can be met they can be
unmet but once the bar is closed that's
it it will not change okay because some
people say well you know it's repain P
well no it's it's not technically
repainting in the sense that there a
signal is not a signal all a so now you
know I load my chart another time it's
it's there it's not there no as a bar is
forming trades are
happening and you know there's buying
and they're selling and in orderflow
right orderflow reads what's being
traded on the volume at the bid in the
offer rather than what's trading at you
know just oh a traded six or a traded
seven traded you know orderflow reads um
it's traded uh you know 50 on the bid 60
on the offer right so that information
is always changing and so the the
conditions can be met Midway in a bar
early in a bar right just as if you're
looking at a Candlestick just a plain
Candlestick right there's times where it
looks like it's a big you know if you're
looking at um yesterday on a daily chart
on a Candlestick chart in the snps you
know we were down you know it was a big
red candle down most of the day it's
just that that last hour of trading hour
and a half of trading you got that big
rally right and you know in some markets
it was a it was a big red candle down
but then it closed green you I think Dow
Clos green right and did that repaint no
you know it's just the bar is not closed
so the orderflow is still happening
right the trading is still happening and
it's once the bar is closed that's it
it's printed period it's not going to
change so if you're not using the trade
entry signal
you can see a signal it can disappear as
the bar is still forming so if you're
using a a one minute chart for example
right 30 seconds
in you can have a you know a bearish
signal formed but all of a sudden buying
comes in you know the last 20
seconds and it cancels it out okay well
it's not going to you know the signal
will be disappear and the bar will close
and there'll be no signal ever again for
that bar so that it's you know people
sometimes you know get lost in that that
you know the market is still trading you
don't necessarily want to jump the gun
that um you know oh you know a signal
just flashed I got to buy or a signal
just flashed I got to sell you gota wait
for the confirmation of the bar
closing so here this is give you some
examples with the trade entry signal
enabled so this is enabled okay so you
can see the signal bar okay so here in
this example this is the signal bar
but the actual trade signal occurs on
the next bar once it starts moving in
that direction just as down here this is
your signal bar and then the next bar
starts moving and you've got your trade
signal happening here okay now it could
keep you out of some trades like you
know if you have a set of two here it
only move by one
tick um yeah here well all these buys
confirm
themselves but if you disable it right
it's just going to form on every bar
that appears here here here here here
here every bar has it right signal bar
is on the trade signal now these are
those zones I was talking about in the
visuals okay some people like to use
those some people um don't but I'll show
you why I I how I use them so signal box
the zones are on right that's these
zones being drawn out from the signal
bar
if you set it to zero here that will
turn it off right and it'll look a lot
cleaner to the
eye this is where it's set to two some
people like to set it to 25 to see H if
this Market's going to come back you
know potentially maybe you know is it
should I get short here or you know sort
okay it's coming back in here and
they're seeing well you know it came
back into this area where there was you
know bearish order flow what's the order
flow look like now is it bullish or
bearish well it's bearish this you know
as we come back up there and they're
looking to trade
it you know again you know something
depending on on your tool you're using
you may want to use it as support or
resistance levels it's up to you um
again You' set the zones out to a longer
number to 25 all right so markets and
settings right this is the the fun part
there I realize there's many different
types of charts that everybody looks at
and it does get a little bit frustrating
sometimes when I get emails saying oh
can it work on
I I I on this type of chart
well yes generally yes it'll work on
most based most chart types
um you know if you if you do have a
specific question you should email me
specifically the the market that you're
looking at the the chart type that
you're looking at
um and I can go from there but again you
know last thing I want to do is give you
a set of settings that I would use on a
chart that um because I have my own
style of trading my own risk tolerance
and if you're different than me you know
it's not about me creating a bunch of
clones to go out there and take over the
trading world it's about you finding you
know your comfort level in the market on
your chart type uh based on your risk
level so you know a good starting point
there there's different starting points
I'm sort of going to go through some of
these um swing filter
disable contango you can set to one or
disable typ markets I would keep on but
normal conditions use five as a as a you
know if if someone said Mike you know
take a look at this
Market this is where I would start
basically I would start with swing
filter off um normal conditions set to
five Tango set to one and then I would
you know depending on on what I see on
on the market on how it moves that would
make uh the necessary
adjustments um the the absolute lowest
settings that you can have is Swing
filter disabled contango disabled um
normal conditions set to one with tight
markets on that's like the the very
minimum and you'd get a ton of
signals now 0 five and
one okay so when I talk about these
numbers zero five and one that means the
swing filter is turned off so it doesn't
matter what you have in the swing period
normal conditions is set to five
contango is set to
one okay
so let's take a look at you know we I'll
pull up my ninja Trader here in a second
but you know most of markets e minis
mini da you know mini da you could mini
da and gold you could sort of lump
together in um the other setting I'm to
talk about because you know there's
there's times where they're extremely
volatile and there sort of times they
trade a bit normal um it just depends on
on how many signals you want crude oil
net
gas start at at the settings um in most
markets you can use the lowest contango
setting instead of not using it um I
said you know you're really going to
focus on contango if if you're looking
if you're like me and you look at a lot
of
um markets that are not mainstream and
and the reason I do that is because that
that's my background you I I spend a lot
of time at commodity literally commodity
based trading companies where we looked
at uh a lot of grain markets a lot of
oil seed markets
Etc um well here all right let's pull up
ninja
Trader uh where's my chart here all
right
so this
is let me get my settings here
so zero right swing filters turned
off bar bar volume set to
zero well I'll set it to 10 because you
know again you should probably want to
have depending on the markets so most us
markets you don't have to worry about
the the minimum bar volume but if you're
if you're looking at things like m andq
in the middle of the night um if you
have it set to zero you're probably
going to want to put at least 10 in
there normal conditions is enabled set
to five contango set to um one tip
markets okay so click apply I changed
the volume so it's got to go calculating
so if you
have everything installed
properly okay when you add it to a chart
or open up a new chart it will say up
here Order flows flow scalper um you
know one minute
contract and then I'll say calculating
all right and you know people ask me how
do you get the date up there or what's
these lines that you have on here just
really simple okay if you want to add
the date I like to have the date on mine
you go to prop
properties right you just click on the
screen here and you know you get this
thing up just by right clicking on the
screen and left click on properties
click this button show date range okay I
just like to have it so I can you know
for my own
purposes then these red and yellow and
there's a green line on top is this one
current open day high low close it's
just it's a ninja Trader provided
indicator just go scroll down and your
indicator field click on current day
open high low close I like to have some
reference you know are we trading at a
high or trading at a low or going
sideways right so this is 0 five and one
now what it's doing right it's it's when
you set the when you turn off
the
um the think right now the swing
filter right it's not taken into account
trades that happen at swing highs or
swing lows it's taking into account
everything that's happening now if you
want to I'll show you something here so
I have the trade entry signal enabled I
have the zones disabled right if I set
it to a level three right just give me
know it'll draw out the zones three
price levels just to give you an idea
of what it's going to look
like um because I'm going to show you
you know some markets that that you're
better I think you're better served um
depending on your trading say you're
training on a dome right and you're just
looking for those quick hits in and out
you're probably going to want to use
the zones right just so you know that
you're still bullish or bearish in the
order flow right so this is why I use
the trade entry signal right because you
can see here let me put this Crosshair
on right you had this move down right
then you had some buying in the order
flow that was bullish but it didn't
follow through right you don't want to
take this trade just as you don't want
to take this trade right you still want
to be
um bearish right to catch that move down
just as uh let me find another example
right here you're going up right yeah
you know there was some bearish order
flow that came in here but it didn't
continue right so you don't want to all
of a sudden you don't want to be getting
out of this position you want to try and
hold it uh for
more all right so this is you know now
at in the evening session
right if you're like me sometimes and
you can't sleep and you want to start
trading in the evening session and and
scalping um you can right and this is
why I like using these zones is sort of
to to tell me that hey you know what
this order flow is is still bullish or
or still bearish right just like as if
in in here you know it's it's very quiet
right it's trading very tight market
right this is at 10:00 uh Thursday night
okay so you know you're getting some
sell signals some sell signals then it
just goes here and it's just trading
very tight okay
now it's actually going back and forth
back and forth you know you get some
bullish order flow bearish order flow
but I'm already
short so you know it's slightly more
bearish order flow right and by having
the trade signal
on you know I don't want to be getting
out here I don't want to be necessarily
getting out here you know I'm short okay
yeah we hit this sort of swing low
bounce up I see there's bearish bearish
bearish even though there's there's some
bullish buying on on a market that's
going nowhere right this market right
now is five and a half bit you know five
and a half at five and three quarters
right it's basically one tick but it's
telling me you know this overall order
flow is still
bearish you know so you know it's just
something to you know keep in mind right
this is you know yesterday this is the
day before um you know so there there's
moves to be had if you want to use a
swing filter right so we'll enable the
swing
filter five
so what you're looking for is you know
swing highs or swing lows right there
there's going to be a lot less
signals
oops so just give it a second here
well let's take a look at some questions
here while it's coming up
uh well there's a lot of questions
coming in um do I trade Lumber no you
know Lumber is
uh kind an interesting story about
lumber from when I was on the floor my
early days so this is with a swing
filter okay so you can see yeah you had
a trade here kind of went sideways but
you got a nice trade here nice trade
there it's really just looking for
swings in the market
right again this is with the zones
on you know I mean some nice moves to be
had in in the night session this what
you know I was I read some study where
actually most this past
year most of the moves have been
happening in the night session um
you know but there's there's
good moves like like the new highs the
new lows have been being made mostly in
the night session right just going back
you know if if you want sort of more I
hate to use the term more pure signals
look at um using a swing
filter
so let's take a look at uh another
market so I'll go back to the 051
well disable that five and one we'll
keep that the same
um I'll go I don't well we'll go to
NASDAQ now
uh I been getting some questions on
NASDAQ so I'll take a look at NASDAQ
and I'll show it to you with 051 which
is no swing filter
five and know strength of five and
strength of one for contango there's
going to be a lot of
signals okay so this is NASDAQ so okay
you can see here right there's a lot of
back and forth um honestly this
yesterday the last you know from before
the cash close the last hour and a half
Trading just Bonkers um you know you got
some a buy down here sell Buy Buy sell
buy or buys um but you know during the
day you're getting some nice moves this
is with basically signal on anytime the
conditions are met right so if you're
like I said if you're using a dome you
probably depending on the market you
probably want to use it but what you
want to do on markets that are are
volatile is you're going to want to use
a swing filter so just enable it we'll
use 55 and one as opposed to 0 five and
one and take a look and you know it's
it's interesting because you know
somebody asked me a question the other
day about U hey can I use it on bitcoin
I'll show you a Bitcoin chart but
honestly people don't really scalp I I'm
sure there are people that scalp Bitcoin
most of the people I know that by
cryptos or Bitcoin it's just you just
buy in hodal right you just buy and and
check the market 100 times today without
without any intention of selling um so
this is NASDAQ yesterday with the swing
filter on right it's a bit cleaner
you're not getting sort of that that
back and forth action um even though it
just sort of happens on every bar you
know NASDAQ is a bit of
a volatile Market in the sense that you
know it's like a cardiac market right it
makes these big moves and then you know
it's just sort of chugs around back and
forth um you know if you have if you're
trade NASDAQ right you got to have stops
right you know that on NASDAQ you get
bars like this right as it just went
parabolic here from 60 and a quarter all
the way up to 79 that's almost a 20
point move it's a one minute chart okay
so that's why you know NASDAQ is
definitely the market you're going to
want to have tight stops on right you
know here was a buy then boom got a nice
sell there this is you know at nighttime
um you know some nice sells here
here you know the day before in the
NASDAQ right so 55 and one in the NASDAQ
right these are the settings again this
will be recorded I'm going to send it
out to everybody so you can sort of see
the settings in here
551 you know just you know again in the
evening session Asian hours you know
this this move here you know what is
that 81 to 86 then from 86 you got the
reverse signal down down into the 70s so
on
um you know the day before the 16th I
don't know what day was the 16th
Wednesday um s it came down in here then
you had that nice rally there uh you
know you just go back you know a lot of
signals that's NASDAQ you know silver
silver is also a market that trades in
my opinion a bit like NASDAQ um I would
use the same signal five five5 and
one um is the silver already yeah
yeah again this is what the zone so it
might be a little confusing to some
people because like what's this why is
there no signal there it's because I
have the trade entry signal on if I have
the zones drawn off you wouldn't see
this you would just see the the sells
and the buys the up and down
triangles you know um silver again you
know silver I find is a nice Market
honestly I silver wasn't on my radar
till someone just you know I was just
talking to him a few weeks ago and he's
like hey you know silver market is
if you like Bitcoin you better like you
should like silver okay I'll start
monitoring silver um gold you know gold
is one of those markets that go either
way um swing filter no swing filter
depends on how you're trading right if
you're just looking for the quick hits
in and out um in short times uh short
time periods uh you're probably not
going to want to use the swing filter
this is what it looks like with the
swing
filter going back again night session
some nice trades yester uh the day
before the 17th um some nice trades if
I'll show you exactly so if you're using
if you take off the swing filter it's
sort of looking for sort of you know
momentum reason I have the swing filter
on is you know people like to trade
momentum some people like to you know
which means basically trade every
bullish signal um where some people want
a more relaxed trading environment and
you know looking for
swings if I I should turn off the uh
zones because it confuses people
sometimes
again if you want to use the zones you
can if you're using a tool like markers
it's just reading the up and down
triangle it's got it doesn't use the
zones at all it's really using all it
references is the up and down triangle
so you know if you're in moves you know
you just find a nice better example you
know this was a move you know here was a
move up right you got blue blue blue you
know down red red red you know things
like that you know from here blue okay
you're not you know when you trade right
try and trade in context of the
market right if if you just if you
notice the Market's rallied up from 1881
and you're now trading $ 1892 $10
move can you get long here yeah of
course you
can you're better served in my opinion
buying after a move down um or selling
after a move up you know again but if
you're training momentum you know you
just want to jump in and and and write
it um let's take a look at you know some
other markets you know I know people now
are interested in markets like Ultra
bonds
okay Ultra bonds is you know it's it's
like it's basically the the new 30-year
Bond the the original ZB is um more of a
20-year Bond B and Ultra Bond is is more
the the real 30-year Bond but again if
you know you're trading Ultra bonds
right Ultra bonds is a nice Market it
moves
nicely it
uh you know it's worth like what 3125 a
tick I
believe and you know just like the
regular bonds but you get some really
nice moves you know this is one where
you'd want to keep you either the zones
on or you know trade the momentum so you
can see you know it'll just keep you
going right you see well still bullish
sorry Still bearish Still bearish Still
bearish you know when it's $31 a tick
you just need to
make um a few ticks at a time and and
this is really where the flow
scalper was created for you know
honestly the reason that we created this
I wanted to have this coded is
because I'll just show you right this
Market that I trade in Malaysia kli
is it's a nice market right it Trends
nicely right and you know you going
these nice drops
here right oh Still Still bearish Still
bearish Still bearish you know Ultra
bonds trade very similar to this this
Market um yeah I just wanted something
that's keeping me on the right side of
the market you know I would read the
orderflow but you know some I said you
know that that's a market that trades
overnight in the US I'm in Chicago and
you know sometimes I I I lose a little
bit of um concentration and I I really
needed something that was taking what I
was looking at and putting it in you
know this is the night session in Ultra
bonds you know look at that there nice
moves you know Bitcoin the Futures
honestly I don't know anybody that
trades the Bitcoin Futures everyone
trades the this the spot but
um you know Bitcoin F you part of the
problem is everybody all the Brokers got
very High margins on bitcoin um but you
know it's the same thing you know I do
honestly for Bitcoin I just buy and hold
I'm sort of oblivious to price but um
you know when I buy it at coinbase I
Accounts at coinbase and I just you know
every week I just buy a small amount but
um yeah you know it's you're still
getting these nice moves you know in
Bitcoin Bitcoin and Ultra bonds move a
lot alike um crude oil let's take a look
at crude oil I know a lot of people
people look at crude so let's go and
jump crude
[Music]
uh again what's this settings are
still still the
same swing filter turned
off normal conditions five Rango
strength
one see see you getting this move down
move down let move up um
you know back and forth now you know
some people say well you know I don't I
don't look at a minute based chart I
look at you know a five minute chart
okay let's go a five minute chart
honestly I don't look at 15
minutes very much um you when you're
dealing with the order flow you got to
remember it's what's happening right now
when you start going out on longer time
frames on order
flow you're you're really giving up a
lot of the utility of the order flow
that's happened in the first minute
because if you're on a 5 minute or you
know a 15minute
bar and the first three minutes are very
bullish okay you know you got a bar it
moves up it moves down and then just
sort of closes sideways you're not
taking advantage of that order flow I
mean that that's you know that's why I
think you know you're going out Beyond 5
10 minutes even 15 minutes is is a bit
of a stretch so this is cral oil on a on
a f minute chart you know it's just it's
the same settings you know maybe you you
might want to adjust
um you know maybe the flow strength but
you know I don't know I'm I'm still
using this the same settings you know
and you're still catching some nice
moves right you know you get long here
okay you got a short here just go
sideways you know maybe you know if you
read the order flow you could recognize
that the market is going sideways you
can get out you don't need to let the
market stop you out this is you know
this is sort of the the battle between
people that trade on a robot you know
want to automate everything
is there there's probably a lot of good
reason in here to get out rather than
let the market come up and stop you out
and take the loss and then you got a
nice trade here wouldn't you rather you
know ride this long up here get out here
okay you get short but it's just not
going anywhere one bar two bars three
bars four bars okay yeah I cut it here
rather than let the market uh stop me
out you know 10 cents higher um then you
get the bullish signal you know at 32
you can write it all the way up into you
know the
50s
um you know
the if you're looking
at I'm kind of mixed actually on longer
term charts if using a swing filter or
not using a swing filter I prefer to see
every signal on longer term charts
personally um and people say well you
say here you got you know short here it
got stopped out short here well honestly
you should have been short from up here
right ideally at 72 um this day was a
bit
choppy but uh you know let's take a look
at M I don't know we'll go back to e-
minis so it's still set to uh 051 this
time let's take a look at a f minute
chart
uh give me a second let me drink some
water but yeah I'll take a look at Dax
daxon um
NASDAQ very similar uh in terms of price
movement so this is again so this is a
five minute chart on E
Minis and you see I got the swing filter
turned off it's just set to five Tango
set to
one again you know I don't want to see
well I caught this big move you know
honestly this move once it started it
was just very bullish till till the
close of the day but look at this you
know right after the cash
open you you got that nice sell off
here um evening session middle of the
night you you had buy here okay got
stopped out or you covered it at a small
loss um but then you got came right back
with with a nice trade from you know
basically the O2 area up until here then
maybe you got you you tried shorting
this you got stopped out tried shorting
this got stopped out then it came back
with a nice a nice move
up um you know the day before again a
lot of chop but still um nice move down
here nice move up there in the evening
session said don't discount the evening
sessions a lot of people discount them
um there's some great movements in the
in the evening
sessions it's
almost I'll say almost better than the
day session but um you get you're
getting a lot of price movement at night
you this was the
15th Tuesday you know look at that on a
FIV minute chart
um you know go back to
Monday initially looked bullish
and turn bearish if you change the again
this is set to 0 five and one but just
really quick you know if you change this
to
say a slightly lower number I don't know
we'll go two or three go three um show
you how it affects
it that's why I say you know start
at um 051 and and sort of go from there
depending on the market like I said you
know there's so many markets but uh
it really depends on on what you're
trading after this I'll take a look at
Dax um and then I'll go into you know
sort of the currency Futures contracts
because that's a market that you're
going to want to use um contango with so
you can see here there's slightly more
signals you you're get sort of a bunch
in here um you got a couple extra buys
here before the market you know that
would if you're long from in here you
know that would have maybe hopefully
would have broken even I wouldn't
suggest getting long up here after you
just missed this big if you missed this
Buy Signal here but um you can see
there's just more slightly more signals
on a lower setting okay so all right
let's go back to a one minute chart um
Dax where are you
here but I'll go back to the original
setting which is the setting that I use
for Nasdaq which is 55 and
one so just give it a second
to load the
data now people say oh Mike it's so slow
well it's once you have your chart open
right for the
day you don't necessarily want to keep
changing it um you just you open it up
you keep it open like I said you know
nowadays you get computer so cheap video
cards so cheap you could put a lot of
monitors on um I said I've got three
monitors on this
PC that's the wrong Dax it's last
month's um thought I had it
updated but it's first time you're
pulling up data on a new contract it's
got to pull all that data down it's got
to download it all okay yeah Chris
uh ah ninja Traders killing
me Dax futures
you got to click on the exact one here
there we go um March
Dex so change the setting to uh did I
change it five zero five and one okay so
you can see like Dax
okay again you know the cash close I
forgot the exact time it's around 10
10:30 Chicago time um cash hours is
uh was is that 2 a.m. Chicago time till
about 10: a.m. so you see this is with
no swing filter with Dax just like
NASDAQ I would use a swing filter
five right so it's going to clean it up
um you know a bit more right so you're
not going to get all that choppy signals
in there because you know Dax is trades
like NASDAQ right it could be all over
the place pretty quick
um yeah it's funny you know the evening
session would be considered all this
time after 11:00 a.m. um it's evening
time in Germany but
um you know some decent decent signals
the Dax is what 25 EUR a tick um so big
contract in terms of margin as well as
in terms of thick value but hey you know
what if you could short it up here at
you know what 85 990 and get a nice move
down into the 50s it's happy days for
you you know just like here right a move
from 605 70 up above
um double O you know that that's those
moves that you like in the decks make
your
day and know here's a little move down a
little move up a little back and forth
before it finally settled bullish order
flow then
boom that big move up um this is Dax
you know some yeah again you know a lot
of these these European contracts even
though they trade until um you know the
Futures Clos in the US
3:00 really
after 11 you know don't you don't really
want to be focusing in them on them much
I mean it's going to follow the snps but
uh you know you really want to be
trading them during the European
session I used to trade a lot of decks
when I was at Commerce Bank and and I
had a two two lot out trade back in the
90s for two days wasn't discovered
turned out to be like almost a $100,000
loser
um buns okay buns just really quick for
the Europeans buns is great
contract
um you can move in and out real easy a
lot of
liquidity I'll just uh I would trade
buns or the the same way I trade uh
Ultra bonds or even 10 years 5 years I I
would not use the swing filter you can
if you're using a minute based chart um
you know this
is a minute based chart because you know
in
buns you want to catch the immediate
movements in the Buns you know as you
want to mimic what the market is doing
right you want to be trading on the side
of the market right if you're short here
coming down into new lows okay what do I
do I cover here do I cover here well
it's still telling me to stay short stay
short stay short stay short stay
short um you know again you know some
nice moves down nice move up but again
you know buns again you know cash Market
in Germany closes about what 10 10:30
Chicago time so after that time that's
already considered even though it's
still open for trading that's really
considered the
the the evening session over there but
you know like here right right off you
know you get get short let's say you're
short here right then okay boom you got
a buy you get
long then it's got a short signal okay
he gets short it's not working out then
okay you got a buy signal right then it
says okay stay long stay long stay long
stay long stay long you know from 40 all
the way up into this into the 60s where
you got your first bearish um order
flow um this was obviously on the FED
announcement the big push down
um you know but the same thing right
stay short stay short stay
short
now let's see go back to here so 55 and
one um for volatile
markets 05 and one so here 55 and one
the markets you look at if you're in
these markets you know 55 and one NASDAQ
M andq
Dax
silver gold could go either way 0 five
and one or five five and one